as a developer you want to quickly
deliver great cloud applications like
web apps mobile api's and background
jobs but choosing a cloud solution often
comes with trade-offs on the one hand
you can choose to manage your servers
but this can mean provisioning and
configuring them yourself plus worrying
about scaling as traffic patterns change
and you might run the risk of over
provisioning resources and paying for
more than what you need on the other
hand you can pick a traditional
serverless solution but this can limit
the languages and libraries you can use
and may require code changes and make it
harder to move your application what if
you didn't have to make that choice and
could enjoy the best of both worlds
introducing cloud run bringing
serverless agility to your containerized
apps you can use cloud run to deploy any
stateless HTTP container this lets you
write your code in your favorite
language with the framework or binary
library that works for you then simply
specify the language your dependencies
and your start script in a docker file
and with one command package it up into
a container and boom you're good to go
your app is now deployed and running in
the cloud you can forget about
provisioning or managing servers cloud
run does that for you cloud run
automatically and quickly scales up or
down based on your incoming traffic and
even scales down to zero and you pay
only for the resources that your app
uses build down to the nearest 100th
millisecond and because cloud run is
built with K native you can use it with
your own kubernetes engine cluster too
with cloud run on gke you can build and
deploy apps to your own kubernetes
cluster with the same easy experience
and benefits so the next time you want
to build a great app quickly check out
cloud run get started today